-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Vice President Kamala Harris.
Obviously, you have to make
a great many sacrifices
to hold this office.
But is it true that you
can no longer send emojis?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, high-class problems.
I have not received directly
an emoji in a year and a half.
-Wow. And you can't have your
staff, like, print them off?
-I mean, I suppose they could,
but they're not
coming to me directly.
Or, you know, for example,
our family is very competitive,
be it Wordle or other things.
And, you know, the family group
chat is no longer a thing.
-Wow.
-Like, you know, it was my
father-in-law's birthday,
and we were talking to the kids.
And I thought, "Okay.
The kids can do
a video for his birthday."
And, normally, I'd send
the family text, but this time,
we had to do like a phone tree.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-It's very outdated to actually
do an old-school phone tree.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I think one of the nice things
about the office is you get to
live in the Naval Observatory.
One of the current, I would say,
downsides of that
is the governor of Texas,
Greg Abbott,
is participating in
a piece of political theater.
He is sending migrants,
basically dropping them off
at your doorstep.
-Yeah.
-I don't think that, you know,
playing games
with people's lives
is the solution to this problem.
But based on the record amount
of arrests at the border,
it is a problem.
I think we look to our leaders
at times like these.
What is the path forward?
-Well, let's start with
the first point that you made.
I mean, we're talking about
people who have
fleed great harm --
They've fled great harm.
And they are coming here
seeking refuge.
And talk about
political theater, I mean,
playing games
with people's lives --
with their lives --
you know, there were mothers
with sleeping babies
getting off those buses.
And I just think it's an
absolute dereliction of duty.
If you see a problem,
and if we agree that we need
to address it,
then if you're a leader,
participate in a solution,
right?
When we first came in office,
the first bill
that we proposed was
for a pathway for citizenship --
was to fix a broken
immigration system,
which was broken under
the previous administration.
Participate in the solution
because we are
offering solutions.
But instead, this gamesmanship
with real human beings
who trust us...
-It's very haunting to watch
human beings being used
as props like that.
There's a great amount
of heaviness to your job.
Do you have any time
in your life to relax
and do anything
where you can unwind?
You mentioned Wordle,
but that doesn't take that long.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
If you're spending more than
five minutes on Wordle,
I think it's time to...
-Well, no, I mean,
to your point, there's also
"The New York Times" --
the crossword
you can do in seconds.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you do the mini?
-Yeah, I do the mini.
Don't tell people
you do the mini.
[ Laughter ]
I don't have time, right?
-That's right.
-I did it in 50 seconds.
I'm very proud of that.
-That's true.
If you can do it --
I don't want the Vice President
doing the Sunday crossword.
I don't know
what I'm talking about, yeah.
-But we -- Doug and I,
one of our favorite shows
right now
is "House of the Dragon."
-Okay.
-We're watching that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you enjoy watching
a political system
that's maybe
more damaged than ours?
[ Laughter ]
-Because there's
no ambiguity about it, right?
You're either riding a dragon
or you're not.
[ Laughter ]
You know, we love --
And Ella's here.
We love -- the whole family,
we watch Formula 1
racecar driving.
-All right.
Look at that.
-So, like, Sunday mornings,
if we're all around --
depending -- I mean,
I was just in Japan yesterday,
but if it's close
to the same time zones...
-That's nice.
When you and the first gentleman
watch TV at night,
is one of you more likely
to fall asleep first?
'Cause this is an issue
my wife and I have.
[ Laughter ]
-Um, yeah, it depends.
-Okay.
He can sometimes, you know,
start snoring.
-Okay.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-But, generally,
we're up at the same time.
-That's very nice.
That's good.
You know, again,
I think it can get overlooked.
And I'm sure,
over the course of your day,
you have to focus on the job
the way anyone
focused on the job in the past.
But you did make history.
And I'm wondering, are there
times when it sinks in for you
maybe more than others
that you are the first woman
to hold this office?
This is a photo that I just
think speaks to the fact that,
for these kids there,
that must be a thing that's,
I mean, hard to fathom.
-You know, that little girl
that you're showing here,
she was so spectacular.
This was an elementary school
in Connecticut.
And I said to her,
"You know, you can be anything
you want to be."
And this kid looked back at me,
in my eyes, and she said,
"Well, I intend to be
everything."
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
-Right?
It was so --
I mean, you know,
those are moments of pure joy,
right?
When you see that kind of
light and enthusiasm, that --
-You must never --
when you're in a class
with elementary school students,
you must not want to leave
because I imagine the rest of
your day is pretty downhill.
[ Laughter ]
-But, I mean, truly, you know,
when you see our kids --
and I truly believe
that they are --
our children, they are the
children of our country,
of our communities.
I mean, our future is really
bright if we prioritize them.
And, therefore,
prioritize the climate crisis
and the need to address it.
If we think about our children,
prioritizing the need
to bring our country together.
I travel around the world.
I've met 100 world leaders
either by phone or in person,
talked with them, right?
From prime ministers
to presidents
to kings to chancellors.
And we still,
as the United States,
can walk in these rooms
with a certain level
of authority
to talk about
the importance of democracy,
the importance of rule of law,
the importance of human rights.
And that gives us
standing in the world.
And when we continue
to invest in our country
and invest in those priorities,
I think it's for the betterment
of everyone.
But certainly, when we think
about it in terms of
the future of our children,
I think we have
a great responsibility.
-You --
[ Applause ]
Obviously not a lot of people
have had your job,
but you do work
with someone who has.
You work with
a former vice president.
-Yes, yes, our president.
-Does the president ever also
give advice on your position?
-You know, I will tell you,
first of all,
I loved Joe Biden.
And -- I really do.
[ Laughter ]
-It's probably for the best
that he can't send emojis,
let's just say.
[ Laughter ]
-But, you know,
he is very thoughtful.
And he is very kind.
And, you know,
so he is thoughtful about,
you know, the American people,
in terms of the work we've done.
And it's been historic work,
how we've lifted up
working families, how we've
invested in infrastructure.
The biggest investment
in the climate crisis,
historic, $370 billion.
But what I will say, in terms of
the interpersonal relationship,
is he knows the job, and he
cares about the partnership.
And in that way,
it makes it a real joy,
given all that
we actually need to address,
in terms of the challenges
our country faces.
But he really is
quite wonderful.
And, yes,
having been vice president,
he knows what the job involves.
-Well, I appreciate
that he and you both
made time for you
to be here today.
It was really special
talking to you.
-Thank you.
-And do come back soon.
You guys, that's our
vice president, Kamala Harris.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back
with Geena Davis.